[Music]
now to bring up your husband mr. Jerry
O'Connell sorry Steve
he's on Broadway right now yes he's
doing a play called seminar with mr.
Alan Rickman no and Rickman they're a
very good play trig actor and and and
you are home alone I gather with your
twin daughter twin daughters who are
three years old I don't get a whole lot
of time to myself it's you know a lovely
experience raising three year old twins
I don't ever get to see my friends
anymore but I did get a girls night out
recently last week yes I went to see my
friend Molly we were gonna go to an
event at a very nice hotel and I got we
were gonna meet at the bar at the hotel
and I got there 15 minutes early and I
was sitting at the bar
and someone sent me a drink and I
listened I was all dressed up I was
wearing an LBD little black dress not
unlike the one I'm going to I didn't
imagine it perfect you know I put myself
together yeah and I was sitting at the
bar and somebody sent me a drink and I
was like okay and then moments later the
gentleman came over and introduced
himself is Pedro an older gentleman from
Spain and asked me if I would like to
join him and his friends and a whole
group of older gentlemen at another
table were waving at me and I realized
that they mistook me for a woman of the
night Wow they thought I was a hooker
yeah I yes and I was mortified wait a
minute more defined I mean at the moment
I was mortified and I'm later I was like
okay mom of twins yeah hold it together
tonight yes when I'm mistaken for a male
gigolo I
I'm slaughtered often women come up and
say we don't know who you are your
prices must be sky-high ago she ations
you know right I'm hoping it was like
high class not like you know cheapo yeah
we don't know I'm sure now I'm in a trap
there's nothing I can say oh no you'd be
a high-class hooker come of this
probably take credit cards
you're welcome